so tell me a little bit about where
things are most busy because i'm curious
i know
that the kind of series a plus thanks to
tiger is super active
is the pre-seed and seed stage just as
busy as
the later stages i would say yes
but i would say it's close so what's
happened is anybody who's got a series b
marketplace or sas company is a good
question anybody who's a marketplace sas
company or consumer subscription that's
growing if you're a growing company
you're going to get a valuation that is
double what it was
three or four years ago so what would
have been okay
you're doing 10 million dollars we'll
give you five
seven times that so we'll do a 70
million dollar evaluation
an 80 million valuation now all of a
sudden it's 10 to 20. so you got 10
million dollars in revenue
you're going out for your series b
between 100 and 200 million would be the
valuation
and they'll be people lining up to put
in that 20 million dollar check
and so what i've told them is if you
were if you're planning on raising money
at any time in the next 18 months
do it now do it now do it now yeah
because
it's like there's a party people are
popping bottles
if you want champagne get a glass
yeah somebody's going to top you off
like you should go get that champagne
right now and then you don't deploy it
slowly
and then what's happening at the earlier
stages which is really weird that i've
never seen is
not quite this craziness at the series b
level that was well documented with
tiger and other people participating now
what's happening is somebody will close
a one million dollar round
you know what for ten percent of their
company and maybe they would have
previously been a six seven or eight
million dollar company but in that zone
it doesn't really matter all that much
because the outcomes are so much bigger
okay if you're an early stage investor
you get comfortable with a 12 million
valuation where it might have been six
previously the round fills up people
find out the round is filled up
and then another two million dollar
shows up and says oh
this person or that person who's notable
is in the round we want to do your
serious sayings
we haven't gotten the money for half
this round in
the wires haven't hit yet we can't why
is the next one exactly
and so what i say to folks is close that
round
give everybody a hard date your money
gets in friday if you don't get your
money on friday
we've now opened a note at 20.
and i've had a dozen companies do this
where they closed the 12 million
round literally the next week they
opened a note for 20 million and then
they say to any other investor
we closed that round we were massively
oversubscribed we have a 20 million
dollar cap note that we're going to keep
open for the next year
for value-added investors we consider
you one of those
if you want to be in that round we're
happy to have you
but or we can wait until we formally
start the round and then those are
starting to fill up
wow so pretty sorry the amount of money
being
slung around in the startup world really
does to me mirror the amount of money
we're talking about with these public
company earnings because
the numbers are getting to be almost out
of my ability to reckon with them
microsoft and apple both north of two
trillion dollars
at some point i began to lose it like i
think around 100 billion i begin to lose
my feet on the ground and float away and
these valuations are very similar
because i
i understand the math you're talking
about when you say if it was six and now
it's 12 post okay
exits are bigger and it's preceded money
and
okay totally but like when i was
learning about dc 10 12 13 years ago
people were talking about how they had
to have price control and all this stuff
and i feel like everything that i was
taught
is now just gone like i learned about
the stock market when exxon was the
biggest company in the world
that's a freaking different era like
it's a it's an entirely brave new world
and i'm
it's fun but my gosh if you think about
the multiples are compressed
even as big as these two trillion three
trillion dollar companies are
their multiple is compressed because
people
assume it can't grow like a startup
but amazon or let's say youtube the
better example
80 year-over-year growth that's startup
level growth like later-stage startup
growth
early stage you're trying to triple
quadruple your revenue year over year
from a million to three or three to nine
once you get up to 100 million you're
trying to get to 150
when you're at 500 million you're trying
to grow to
750 800 you may not double year over
year i mean you can but it's not easy
and you look at amazon 113 billion in
revenue for the quarter
just it's absolutely crazy but jason you
forgot the punch line to that particular
joke what happened this morning to
amazon's stock
went down it went down now now tell the
people why
because this is the funnest part of the
show they missed their revenue number
by one billion i think it was a little
bit more than that but essentially
they were 115 was the expectation they
hit 113. yeah i think
from corey yeah but just looking at the
run rate of 443 billion
is insane and then you just
compare that to gdp they would be the
27th
in the world it's pretty extraordinary
they would be
right by austria and iran yeah so here's
why i think amazon
took a bit of a hit if you look at their
um q2 earnings report and you spend a
lot of time
going past all the bullet points they
put on top about new kindle features
they announced
that you're not going to use i love that
i don't know why they still do that like
why did they do that it's like really
you
you even produced the kindle oh when's
the last time i even saw a kindle
okay let's not erase ebooks here i own
two kindles and i'm a big fan but like i
use them to read
to be clear if you go to the financial
guidance section of the amazon qt report
you'll see that for q3 of this year
compared to the last year
they're expecting net sales to grow
between 10 and 16
so amazon has reached the end of its
pandemic growth surge and i think
investors had
higher expectations and critically it
was priced like it was going to grow
more quickly and so it lost some of that
growth premium
amazon still had a great quarter if i
ever do 113 billion in a quarter please
put a pound on my head and a scepter in
my hand
but compared to expectations and how
they were valued it was a bit of a miss
and so
i friends who struggle with like great
quarter and it's a miss and it's
it's technical but it was a surprise i
think to a lot of folks when they saw
the headline number and then what
happened to the stock
yeah and there's also going to be this
changing of the guard jeff
is no longer in charge so i think that
makes some people nervous
and there's got to be some profit taking
going on if p if this was like such a
pandemic run-up and everybody was
getting their
six months worth of remember that last
year oh yeah six months on your shelves
and like
fighting for wipes and we were wiping
our food
down and wearing gloves and masks to
unpack our cereal
i i i was one level below that whatever
level of panic that was i was one step
down
but not not too far different i
literally remember a month of
wiping my groceries down and like
wearing
my wife is like don't bring that into
the house i'm like
the tomato soup don't bring into the
house okay i'll wipe it down it's okay
i can talk i can top this though we had
we had a friend in town from college and
she was in town for three months we did
dinners every week
outside at her house it was lovely
actually and she said that her family
early in the pandemic where they would
order food in and then they would
re-microwave it
to kill off whatever and they were
actually microwaving their salads
before they ate them and i was like
there it is yeah i don't know the
peacock i have covered this
yes yeah i don't think your salad has
that don't you want warm salad jason
just lots of limp lettuce
i like i'll tell you the free say salad
with the warm egg and the lardon on it
yeah
that slide that's fine
today many small business owners are
busier
than ever and because they're focused on
managing and growing their businesses
they
can't spend the time they need you on
recruiting and that's why linkedin jobs
has made it easier
to find and hire the best candidates for
free we have had such a great experience
finding two more producers for this week
in startups
researchers to sort through all the deal
flow i get and it has been amazing
it's a great place for you to look for a
job and it's even better place for you
to post a job
so many talented people are sitting
there waiting to hear
about your career options for them
and we use targeted screening questions
to get our roles in front of the most
qualified candidates
with the experience skills and
motivation we need then we use simple
tools to filter and prioritize the top
candidates
for interviews and best of all
linkedin's network now has over 740
million professionals all over the world
linkedin jobs is going to help you find
the right person for your
role they're so confident that you're
going to love linkedin jobs
they're letting you do that first job
posting free every week
nearly 40 million job seekers visit
linkedin
they're waiting to hear about their
next career adventure and you just have
to go to linkedin.comtwist and post that
job listing for free
so that you can make their dreams come
true
and have that great employee join your
team what are you waiting for
you can get that free job posting right
now linkedin.com twist
terms and conditions apply because
they're giving you something for free
yada you know how it goes